[Music]
kerry is with us carrie is in peoria
illinois
hi gary how are you hi
good thank you dave for taking my call
sure how can christina help
um so we all know this has been a tough
year
for us we've been very blessed because
we've had our jobs um
my husband's a machinist and tool guy
and he is in the army reserve
um so we saved up 24 000 and we have
twenty two thousand dollars look at that
um so we're wondering if we should just
buy the bullet and just pay it all off
and
leave 2020 behind us or just use some of
it and
have like our emergency fund set down
um we wouldn't do partial we're going to
do one of two things where they're going
to keep doing what you're doing
piling up cash or we're going to push
play
on the baby steps and immediately pay
off use everything but one thousand
dollars and pay on the debts
which it sounds like you can get really
close to or pay off your debts one of
the two
um so the only reason you would push
pause
is if your financial life is unstable
not because the world's gone crazy but
you're looking at your situation going
we could lose our incomes there's a high
likelihood we're gonna lose our incomes
or a high likelihood something else is
coming at us but just the
general bs in the world that's going on
no we don't push pause on that because
some people are having the best years of
their life and it sounds like you guys
are doing fine
um we have we have two children too
they're pretty young
yeah also that's why we're kind of like
hesitant about paying it all off i guess
wait a minute i'm sorry why why do young
children make you hesitant to pay it off
oh i mean like um there's nothing
different
and everything okay well that's just a
general question that has nothing to do
with pandemic or this year
yeah so that's just when you decide if
you're going to work our plan or not
oh yeah i want to my husband's just more
hesitant about it
yeah i understand the thing is this okay
refresh my memory now tell me how much
debt is there
22 000. and how much money do you have
in your account
24. okay all right so we tell you baby
step one is one thousand dollars
after you pay off all of your debt
you're gonna have two thousand dollars
and you will have finished baby step two
and you have no payments right
and with no payments except your house
payment on a tight budget are you doing
a written budget are you doing your
every dollar budget with your husband
yeah i mean i'm the one that writes
everything down
okay good boy needs to get involved
i know i tell him to write stuff down
but he's just no he don't need to write
stuff down he needs to look at the
budget with you and the two of you agree
on and stick to
it yeah he's hesitant because he didn't
know what the flip is going on
yeah you're not his mommy
yeah you're not you're he he's supposed
to be like a grown full man
and the two of you working together on
this thing and that
that that's where his hesitation is
coming from is he doesn't know what's
going on he's got this
vague sense of things so here's the
thing if he was involved in the budget
and the two of you are looking at the
budget
and we're both in agreement we're
unified and you write a check and pay
off all the debt
and you look at your budget and you go
you know we can save two thousand
dollars a month we already got two
thousand dollars in there so next month
we'll have four thousand the next month
we'll have six thousand
the next month we'll have eight thousand
then all of a sudden all this
uncertainty starts to go away because
you're going to build this emergency
fund really really fast
but only if the two of you get on the
same page
yeah so the reason you're struggling
with all this is you're half butt doing
all of it
yeah he didn't get it yeah you cannot
make
cake without putting in the sugar
there's a recipe and the recipe is you
do the written budget and the two of you
work together and you're both fully
informed
there's a tremendous power in that
christy yeah and when you're not having
the conversation that's where all the
ambiguity that's where all the confusion
if you simply have a conversation
explain the why get on the same page
with the what
and the how then i think the hesitation
will uh he won't have the hesitation but
he's just he's not in it you're doing it
and he has the luxury of throwing
grenades at your plan
and he's just sort of pretending to go
along with it but he's not he's not he's
not he doesn't get it he's not going
along with it
and here's the problem carrie that that
increases fights in marriage and it
decreases the probability that you're
going to win with money
when the two of you aren't working
together almost all the millionaires we
interviewed for chris hogan's book
everyday millionaires 10 000 of them
said one of the keys was that they were
working in tandem with their spouse
none of them were dragging along dead
weight
they were working together and they were
tuned in together
and there's a high correlation on that
this is like one of you disciplines the
kids and the other one doesn't you know
it's it's
that's just you know when your daddy
gets home oh that that never happened in
my house we have to wait for daddy we
already got it before he got there
you know and so we knew we knew it was
coming from whichever direction that we
were going to misbehave
and we say that over our kids either you
know you know if when you misbehave you
can expect a problem from anybody that's
an adult in the house
you know and so same thing here you got
to both be
on this and you can't he he needs to
step up he really does you need to call
him out on it and you'll be
kinder than i'm being carrie but the you
should be
actually but the the truth is it's it's
paramount
to the probability of you winning and
that's why i'm so concerned about